from my blood
come the prince that was promised
and his will be the song
of ice and fire
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about house of the dragon episode 2 and
beyond it's kind of a tricky proposition
because unlike its predecessor this is a
complete story that's already been told
it has an ending even if you didn't read
this story back when it was some
novelettes that were published in
anthologies or in the world of ice and
fire or again as the expanded and
complete version in fire and blood you
could still get a fair idea of what's
gonna happen by looking up and reading a
summary online this is not esoteric
knowledge but when thinking about
talking about this show i'm dealing with
two distinct factions the sweet
unspoiled summer children and everyone
else what's interesting about this
trailer i'm going to talk about though
and the general feeling coming out of
episode 1 is that there is something for
everyone today i'm going to break this
in the weeks ahead trailer down so i'm
going to come at this like i did when i
covered the expanse just look at what we
see and discuss it without any book
spoilers about what's going to happen
next and with that out of the way let's
get into it
so first things first as i mentioned
this is a weeks ahead trailer not an
episode 2 trailer in it we see the older
versions of alicent and ronira which are
played by different actors so you can
see that we'll be jumping ahead in time
although based on how much we see them
and what the younger ones are doing in
this trailer it would appear that
they'll be around for several more
episodes i suppose the biggest reveal
for the non-book readers among us is the
shot of king viserys exiting his royal
coach being followed by a very pregnant
allison we saw otto send his daughter to
comfort the king she was somewhat
reluctant but agreed and based on this
shot alone you can see that it will have
major implications for the rest of the
story the show tried to set up a rivalry
over succession between ronira and damon
in episode 1 but what if he had more
children with a second wife episode 2 is
titled the rogue prince which comes from
one of those novelettes i mentioned in
the beginning that is centered on damon
we last saw him leave king's landing
with mazaria after his brother told him
to go home to his wife instead most of
these scenes we see of him in this
trailer appear to be at dragonstone and
then we also see him in several battle
scenes that pop up there's a great shot
of him on karaxi's raining down dragon
fire on some unfortunate fleeing humans
and a shot of him unsheathing his
valerian steel blade dark sister and
pointing it in otto hightower's general
direction at dragonstone their dislike
for each other was well established in
the opener and the fact that mazaria is
standing behind him might be an
indication that he didn't follow his
brother's orders to return to his wife
and the veil otto is escorted by members
of the kingsguard which would make sense
for a hand of the king and before things
get ugly or maybe while they're getting
ugly it looks like rinera drops in on
cyrax to intervene since i know what's
going on here there's not much i can say
that wouldn't be spoilers other than
this all looks great the same goes for
the battle scenes i suppose if you were
really paying attention to the premiere
you might be able to put together what's
happening but i'll just point out that
we see damon engaging in combat on
dragon's back and on the ground you also
see cordless valerian in there mixing it
up looking like he can hold a zone
i mentioned in my episode 1 breakdown
that these are people who are living
through a peaceful time that's been
ongoing so most of the people who take
on the roles of warriors people like
damon haven't seen much combat and you
saw that coming out a little bit in the
way that the gold cloaks were basically
cutting people to pieces in the streets
and it does look like they're going to
get a taste there's also this shot with
a new character wearing a mask and some
soldiers tied to stakes on the edge of
the water with all these crabs running
around out of all of this the daemon
shot that jumped out to me is the one
where we see becerra standing over him
in the throne room the king pulls out
his trusty dagger the same one that
you'll recognize from a couple of key
scenes in game of thrones and tells his
brother you are no conqueror you are a
plague this is interesting for a few
reasons one is it's nice to see becerras
coming with some real emotion in episode
one you get the idea that he has an
issue with dealing with things head on
and gripping up your brother and holding
his life in your hands does have i'm
tired of people not listening to me
energy speaking of that dagger in one of
the scenes with the older versions of
alison and ronira we see the former
coming at her old bestie with it i think
you can surmise she's got something on
her mind here there is an exchange in
the voiceover with renera saying that
she will be the queen of the seven
kingdoms that's followed by allison
saying you may do as you wish when i'm
cold and in my grave but keep in mind
it'll be a while until we get to that
which is evidenced by this being emma
darcy and olivia cook's voices and we do
see quite a few shots of them as well
but just keep in mind this is not coming
from the younger versions this is not
the voices of millie alcock and emily
carey there's also another shot of
becerras holding the dagger which i've
always called the cat's paw because it
was first used by the assassin who came
to kill bran in season 1 of got there's
several shots of him where he sort of
puts his hand on it and touches it in
the premiere so he's got a thing with it
but here he's holding it up while he's
talking to renera telling her the burden
of this knowledge it is larger than the
iron throne it is larger than you this
is definitely related to the family
secret about aegon's dream that he
revealed at the end of the premiere at
the end of my recap i said i wasn't sure
how i felt about that revelation and
that i would have to wait and see where
they go with it and from what we see
here in the trailer it looks pretty
interesting at the beginning you hear
renera say part of that prophecy from my
blood come the prince that was promised
and his will be the song of ice and fire
without getting into direct spoilers or
getting too far into the weeds it does
seem that this is a big part of his
motivation and something that he would
only share with his heir he made a point
of that and there has been a question of
why this didn't get passed down like it
was supposed to it does come back up but
it's discovered by daenerys's older
brother rhaegar so at some point it had
to be written down and forgotten which
means there's a lot of mystery around it
and the fact that it's common knowledge
right here right now with him and his
chosen successor and the fact that this
is not in the books but comes straight
from george rr martin means that there's
this added element that we're all in the
dark about i've kind of been thinking
about it in the sense of what problem
was george r r martin trying to solve
when he casually mentioned this to the
showrunner of this series and so that
gives us all even people who know
exactly how this story going gonna play
out something to theorize about there's
a ton of young rhinera throughout this
trailer we see her on the deck of a ship
on psyrex in the godswood at king's
landing where we see that weirwood again
which is kind of a surprising thing to
be there we see her possibly disguised
as a commoner sneaking past the skull of
belarion with her aunt rhaenys who tells
her that men would sooner put the realm
to the torch than see a woman ascend to
the iron throne and at a ceremony with
the kingsguard looking down at the
comely knight of dornish descent kristen
cole that she appeared to have an
interest in at the torny to tie those
two things together we see her dancing
at a wedding feast with the only son of
rhaenys and corliss lenore and you can
see that she's looking over at kristen
who's standing in the foreground
we see quite a bit of house valerian
here there's a few shots of the sea
snake and him saying our houses are
bound by a common cause this is
promising because he's an interesting
character from a powerful house that
didn't play a large role during the
events of game of thrones in much of the
same way that damon added an element to
exist alongside the palace intrigue of
things in king's landing corliss has the
ability to do that with the more
traditional power players with aegon's
dream in the mention of the prince that
was promised there is some connection to
what will happen later things that
people who watch game of thrones can
relate to and what's great about
prophecy in this world is that it
doesn't have to come true it's equally
interesting to see what people do
because of prophecy as it would be if it
actually played out think of all the
different characters decisions in the
original series and how that shaped the
outcome of things jon snow's parents
rhaegar and lyanna melisandre the list
goes on and i always preferred the
greenseers and skin changers to the
dragonriders so the more connected it
all feels the better as far as i'm
concerned as a book reader what's
exciting about all this footage is that
it seems to be doing justice to if not
elevating things that are familiar from
reading the story the closing shot of
the dragon veigar is a perfect example
you can read that this is the largest
living dragon and you can think about it
being aegon's sister wife visenyas that
she rode during the conquest but seeing
her brought to life to close out an
amazing trailer is a kind of icing on
top that doesn't come around that often
for the unsalted out there you can see
that things are gonna get complicated i
for one am looking forward to seeing how
things play out and i think that's a
great place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you think now that
you had a couple of days to think about
episode one what you thought about this
trailer and what you're looking forward
to if you want to talk book spoilers
that's fine just make sure you mark
those accordingly type in book spoilers
use some line breaks to make sure it all
appears below the fold i'm finding
myself getting sucked back into this
world so let's hope that things go in a
good direction please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon